kangaroo be up in the office do RepRap
it will be to corporation talk about
ownership and leverage a theater
detectives out there's everything
[Music]
there bill get out yeah got a strategic
me like this is out for me just cuz I
feel like I've really got there gently
like I think once it clicked to me I
[Music]
have to put myself in the best machine
you're clean if I don't think of myself
an investor if I just read the peelings
of society and deploy oh well the other
day from my perspective the world small
little world this is a table as
completely naive I think about you know
agencies that are doing 1 to 5 million
and what we can do for them versus what
they can do for themselves independent
it's a one plus one equals 11
yeah totally dick okay I'll let you rock
take the fall I do like that
how's Romania quick I really wanted to I
really wanted to editor come on boy you
like that part I wanted to take that
part out that's what I wanted to edit
out we're really used it has everything
that this artist is so good
so whatever we're doing inefficiently is
super interesting to me and there's two
buckets inefficient which I I know how
good you are at and office know whatever
they're going to want to do I'm going to
slightly move it support the upside of
Arsenio outside in salt on that bit
right after like we anything like moment
do with their work and then be like
we're not doing this program we're
setting the conditions like if one
activist okay everybody out look it's
this this then some forty five five -
yep I'm cold
then Andy Andy then Phil let's go okay
yes good so good how are you good to see
you Jeff and Alain and mark yeah all of
them have been like we time to maybe get
together as a crew okay all right so
really interesting you guys were talking
I just had a guy by name Eric Kastner in
my office
Eric Castro was my first developer at
Wine Library I was there so emotional
like for me even like seven years day in
day out like this I didn't travel back
then and then I haven't talked to him
for six or seven years and I reached out
to him the other day random and said hey
I want you to come and be my personal
developer for my chatbot for my Alexa
skills for all the stuff that I want to
go on the tech offense because I got
everything on the content down but I
don't have that tech partner right now
hip hop really taught me that hip hop
I'm 41 and I was really into hip-hop and
when I was in high school hip hop was
really hardcore you got to be a gangster
II like guys as you guys know made up
their backstories to make it seem like
they came from tougher places
you couldn't be accepted the way you can
now if you grew up in a you know I
always think about eight-mile the last
scene right Clarence's parents you know
like but it's interesting when when when
it changed in like after POC and Biggie
got killed and Bieber like [ __ ] you know
like like let's talk more about like and
it was happening a little bit before
when it got into Champaign and it got
into like you know you know polo shirts
and like umbrellas Bentley ready like
when it when it when it got into a
different thing what it was like oh my
god all those kids thought that was cool
and then we'll never forget it when I
saw a Lil Wayne start caring about
skateboarding I was like okay something
very weird is about to happen because
that yeah and you've seen it right like
it's just in a totally different place
and now entrepreneurs hold that pedestal
which i think is great I think a lot of
you agree right now the key is to teach
kids patience long game self-awareness
doing it the right way you know some
kids sent me an email yesterday and he
said you've changed my life because I
grew up in a really shitty neighborhood
can everybody taught me that hard work
was for suckers
and it really hit me like read it like
four times last night and he's like you
know hard work was round upon but you
got to find your way for the short move
the quick score the angle that you were
good if you did that and it's really
like already I'm like trying to manifest
in my content like okay I got to figure
out what that means and so anyway that's
the answer that's a very long when the
answer to like you know what feel I can
sit here and talk philosophy all I want
but I'd rather do
that's why right now no ship can save
this thing because it's real hard real
hard to become Jerry Rice or Lil Wayne
like real hard like there's only so many
slots but you can make 97 thousand a
year with your small little Jam business
or fastest or like it's there it's the
long tail of ROI of building your
business is so much longer and that's
why I'm excited that entrepreneurship is
winning culturally because a lot more
kids are going to build a hundred
thousand dollar-a-year life for
themselves then until because it's
peaceful famine and athletics and
hip-hop right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]